if you had a movie right yeah I'd say we
had this movie we're gonna make this
movie right
what would you do to one raise the money
to
let the people at least have a chance to
get their money back because you can't
just get people to give money some
stupid GoFundMe thing where they're not
getting their money back why to be to
have your name at the end of a list of
80 names at the credits so what would
you theoretically do I don't even you
probably shouldn't even tell me because
somebody else will end up doing it but
you know what I mean you'd have to
kidnap Joe Rogan's dog or something and
then get you know what I mean like get I
was gonna say you would kidnap our
Christchurch family but that wouldn't
that would have been like Ransom of the
Red Chief where but even but even bird
Chrysler Joe Morgan he would have been
like no I'm like I'm gonna kill your
family give me money Bird's gonna go all
right Tuscaloosa we're going to Ohio see
you in Grand Rapids
um but I'm saying let's say even Joe
Rogan or Bird crush yeah if they gave
you the money yeah how would they get
their money back that problem is getting
the money here's the problem of movies
they cost so much [__] money yeah
they do and distribution's weird because
people aren't buying things online the
way they used to people are used to
subscribing to things like HBO GO or
Netflix or right Paramount they're not
used to an individual purchase the way
they would be you know maybe 10 years
ago the way they bought bought music on
iTunes now they have apple music which
is a subscription
that's one of the problems with it
because you can't know how many people
will buy something and you can't know
how you're going to make your money back
I think the hope would be that after you
made the movie you would have it you
would license it to a Hulu Netflix
something like that yeah but that's
depressing it's very depressing I mean
some you know licensing it it's like you
do all the all this stuff and then the
investors and by the way investors
always they it's hard for them to get
their money back once it goes into those
machines and that's the other problem
you don't want to screw people out of
their money like it's difficult because
everybody because like with podcasts
people have proven they could do late
night shows on their own they go oh I
can basically do and get the audience at
Kimmel or Fallon or Colbert gets
um with sketches online people have
proven they can do a version of what SNL
does that's right I can make comedy
sketches people can you know digest them
and and love them and subscribe to other
things I'm doing
but with movies and similarly with
episodic TV it's very very difficult you
can't make a succession on your own you
can't make a Game of Thrones on your own
these are difficult these are massive
big budget Productions with hundreds of
people top-notch Talent
um it's difficult that's why those
companies still dominate that particular
uh genre of entertainment but I don't
think that's why because
secession Game of Thrones are great but
when you're making when they're making
it's because they promote what they want
and they have the power to control what
people say that's right so for example a
movie like Mean Streets from 1973 at
that time a little boy God knows what
the budget was then right but that kind
of quality
you can't just buy they can't make those
they don't understand how to make a
funny movie of that John they don't
understand so I'm just saying you can
make in my opinion funny movies that are
low budget because we're not trying to
Dazzle them with visual low budget but
you gotta wonder how you get your money
out of it that's what I'm saying that's
the question that's how I started this
conversation right you know I don't know
why suddenly acting like you're asking
me no no no but it's hard I bought this
no you're right I don't have an answer
Oh I thought you did because of the
mortgage thing if 20 000 people buy a
movie for ten dollars that's not enough
50 000 people buy it for ten dollars
that's five hundred thousand dollars
that's nothing so now a hundred thousand
people buy it for ten dollars that's a
million dollars and that's a lot of
people knowing right it's still not
enough let me tell you so let's say you
had a movie okay theoretically let's say
at a movie like one of my movies you
Chris DiStefano
Andrew Schultz right yeah I'll see you
guys are in this movie yes now you will
promote it on your podcast as part of
the thing yeah that's where we go for
promotion No One's Gonna help No One's
Gonna smoke and then you go on other
people's podcasts because they're like
why wasn't i in it right
um so they give you a little passive
aggressive yeah so it's you three guys
promoting how much how many people do
you think you get to buy it it's the big
question mark because right it's a big
question mark because you could look at
all the numbers and say
it should be a certain percentage of the
amount of people you have
but you don't know until it's out there
right and how it's received
well yeah it has to be great well has to
be great and people have to love it and
it's got to connect and people have to
buy it and they have to keep watching it
and keep talking about it it's like all
of that stuff it's hard to know
whereas if like people buy ads based on
a podcast when they go let's say this
guy's got a million or two million
listeners
a percentage of them will click the link
and buy the product you could try that
with a movie and say well the if all add
up all the listeners they have or fans
they have or look at ticket sales look
whatever look at email lists
still who buys it that's the big
question but that's the other thing
because look what I did I did cop show
right cop show yes was internet thing
funny really for everybody I did
everything right it was all funny every
episode's funny all got all these
celebrities at the time to be in it
every episode it's still no eyes right I
mean it was unbelievable because it's
difficult even though something can be
quality yeah it's very hard to get it
like right now the biggest things that I
that I saw go viral were things that
were initially things that people like
hated or did it like little Nas acts
that's on Old Town Road but it's kind of
like it came out it was kind of like a
joke then people were like hey it's kind
of catchy it's actually kind of good
then he became massively famous a lot of
things start as like this like I would
think if we did a movie like this right
we'd have to come up with a marketing
campaign and this is where you go to
Schultz because he's brilliant with
stuff like this
um and we could all figure it out but
you'd have to come up with a marketing
campaign where the people
hot like Blair Witch Project came out
people like is this found footage is
this real right maybe it is now
obviously No One's Gonna think that's
not the angle we use because we're all
known as comedians we still have to find
the marketing angle and Burke Chrysler
is brilliant with this too that really
gets eyeballs on this thing right that's
the challenge that's hard it's you you
put all the work like every comedian
you know you put a lot of it into the
thing you're doing sure but then there's
a whole other which I'm okay at I'm not
nearly as good as other people there's a
whole other job
of getting people to see it yeah
figuring out how I would hire the trans
girl that Dylan Mulvaney from Bud Light
yes I'd hire her yeah I would hire Dylan
Mulvaney to promote the film in the most
grotesque way
I don't even like Bud Light she's just
there with the can and she's gone I love
beer I would have her talking about I
would have her beating her dick with a
hammer yeah just to get attention yeah
just to get any attention you need to
kind of do something like that
controversial people gotta be angry yeah
they gotta be mad it's so it's a it's a
whole different thing yeah cop shows
just a really funny good thing yeah
that's tough you're right people have to
be angry they have to kind of be enraged
well what about this yes we get during
the when we're filming right we have a
camera that's a rogue Renegade camera we
have nothing to do with it right one of
the cameraman's just crazy right and he
catches de Stefano and Dylan Mulvaney
like blowing each other and that's
believable yeah yeah it's perfect and uh
back behind the scenes and then two days
later when people get bored of that we
have seven are trying to strangle Dylan
Mulvaney right he's gonna hit her too
that makes sense yeah there's gonna be
violence as well because we were gonna
do it yeah yeah it's not a bad idea and
she'd be up for it we'd call her agent I
mean she'll do anything and but it needs
to be something like that as much as we
could
without that type of controversy people
it's just because there's so much [__]
out there now that's what it is YouTube
is so big my uncle just watches fishing
yeah on YouTube yeah there are people
and he just watches that yeah he just
watches it like to get to him
you have to get that you have to somehow
puncture that Community the bass boat
Community someone there has got to go
this movie's really funny like
everybody's in their own micro Community
right now